[Music]
ready as I'll ever be
you really think ice close with me all
that different females cool you don't
want people to think I'm lazy
worst case you always have any ID
keeping it clean tidy Oh daddy daddy
everyone is on her feet you guys seem at
ease
eyebrows from last weekend Oh on fleek
what about this go with the football
it's more iconic like a Taylor Swift
song are you so right yes oh you still
don't have a date for the prom
[Music]
Maddie it's not what it looks like so
it's not my boyfriend and best friend
making out for some optical illusion of
that well if you believe that then yes
oh my god why are you doing this now I
know how much being crowned queen means
to you which only makes me want it more
now just reflect and listen to my urine
and the water I reflected my whole life
has been a lie Maddie what's wrong
hey though it's going as we thought that
popular kids in school had anything to
get this upset about maybe she's not
that popular okay why did all of this
have to happen right before prom that's
it what's it prom what if we ruined it
who would want to help us every kid you
and your ex friends ever made
the sweating on your back looks like the
United States of America I'm posting
this this news for all the a-holes and
destroyed high school for us we're in
will make it a night that they never for
that she's gonna take a selfie hold on
we have to take at least 40 or 50 to
make sure we all look good part of me
just wishes I could go to prom destroy
that problem let me take off those
tighty whities are you high but that
doesn't mean I don't mean what I say
[Music]
you guys ready to make this a problem
they will never forget hell yes Don
right now
how do you do this 39 more here you go
[Music]